2024 who who who would you like to see
be the leading candidate or the nominee
for
uh libertarian party representing the
libertarian party uh
no i'm kidding no uh i i really think we
you brought it back you said don't say
the name i was teased she heard it
i happen to agree with the idea of
somebody popular that to me matters
tremendously somebody popular do you
have a name i would take someone like a
drew carey because he know he's he talks
to people who vote his audience is
literally voters right he does the the
price is right show right and they're
all like retired seniors so that's good
because they'll vote for him because
they know him but anybody popular i'm
good with that's what i want someone who
is popular i'm in okay dave
someone really great so i don't have to
do it would be uh good maybe the rock
you have anyone got his number here
would you can we get you would you
consider it because i know they're
throwing your name in there constantly
yeah well i have a lot of people in my
camp within the the libertarian world
who want me to do it and i've kind of
been open and saying that i consider uh
doing it but like if there was i like
kind of in the spirit of what larry said
i really love my career i really love my
family i got two little kids if someone
else could do a really great job at it
that'd be awesome i'd be happy to to do
that but i do think that we have the
reason why i joined the libertarian
party uh is because i think this party
has a real opportunity particularly in
the current political landscape in
america and it's been frustrating to me
to watch the presidential candidates get
this golden opportunity to really i'm
not saying they could win the presidency
obviously that's were many steps off
from that but to really change the
narrative force the other two parties to
have to talk about the issues that we
care about open up tens of millions of
americans minds to a whole different way
to look at how we organize a society
legally and politically
i've seen that opportunity and i feel
like i know what they should be doing
with that opportunity and um if no one
else is going to do it then i i probably
that would be probably i would i would
i'm 39 so i'd be uh 42 or 41. everyone
yeah he's popular i would support him
too anyone who's popular i want to
support not only that he sells it very
well i need some of those he's a
libertarian obviously that should be i
mean libertarian you've got to be
libertarian yes and popular if you're
libertarian and popular i'm in so
question do you have anybody you'd like
to see peter thiel peter thiel okay i
don't know if he would do i think he's
more of a i don't know if he's a
candidate type i think he's more the guy
you want to he's a king
yeah he's behind the closed door did you
want to go yeah so if you if you had to
pick the four people that are asked the
most if they're gonna run for the
nomination it's the three of us and
justin amash but likely i would think i
don't think i'm missing anyone there um
and what i say when i'm asked that is
that uh pretty much a lot of the things
that they've said that it needs to be
someone who is able to uh excite people
who is able to demonstrate that they
actually can do things and provide
solutions someone that is an actual
libertarian i think that is obviously
important uh and someone who who is
popular and has a magnetic personality
and can bring people in i also say that
i don't even really care right now who
our nominee is right now we are talking
about who the next person is to go and
score the margin of error
the reason i started you were the power
is because i want one day for our
presidential candidate in 24 28 whenever
whether it's one of us or someone way
better than us
to actually have a shot of winning and
in the meantime before we get to this
utopian future where libertarians take
over the world and leave everyone alone
that's something we like to say is
actually show
how actually help people now there are
people suffering under the abuses and
excesses of government from the federal
level all the way down to the local
level which is actually where most
tyranny happens is your city council
your county council your state
government now
help them now build coalitions with
people now bring them into the movement
now i am like these two i've been
retired since 2017. i'd like to go back
to being retired i say i'm retired now
it just means i don't get paid i do way
more now than i did when i was working
full-time when i had my businesses but i
would like to go back and enjoy
retirement spend time with my wife too
young to be retired we gotta i'm 39 too
oh dude you're too young to be retired
right we got we got to put that talent
to use for 30 more years you can enjoy
the time with your family yeah oh
but here's the thing i would like to
from a from a political standpoint yeah
not have to do this because we have
built something up that's someone way
more political than any other
involvement you know what i like
you know what i'd like to see happen
here's what i like to see happen folks
if you're watching this you're a
libertarian
go tack musk
non-stop today okay with this
i'd love to see a meeting between the
main voices of libertarians with rogan
and musk just sit down and let musk
destroy you guys in any questions he's
going to ask you and then if he gets to
a point where he says this [ __ ] makes
sense
then for him to go and do what he did
with the trolling stuff with dogecoin
and bitcoin and crypto and all this
other stuff all of a sudden everybody's
talking about it next thing you know you
got a bigger platform the next time
you're running but if you got those two
guys backing you up it's big the other
thing i think that another person that
may be a i know you keep talking about
drew carey i i i i there's something
special about vince vaughn him too uh
there's something he's very very very
very very i don't know how interested he
was in like really being like the the
kind of because he hurts his business
yeah because he is but i agree with you
completely i i also think that right now
there's a really unique thing that's
going on that's really revolutionary
that i'm not sure any of us exactly
understand even those of us who are kind
of in the world but shows like this
and like rogan and tim poole and like a
whole bunch of these other shows that
are like really popular like far more
people are watching this than are
watching the traditional corporate press
and there's this kind of network of all
of these people where a lot of really
powerful wealthy really influential
people are listening to these shows
there's something there where
libertarians now we used to complain for
years that we were kind of denied access
they wouldn't have ron paul on cnn
they'd black him out and all this now we
have this whole alternative
like outlets where we can get on and
talk about the ideas we want to talk
about and we've really got to be good at
utilizing that yeah that's why that's a
lot of like my focus the bitcoining of
media decentralization of media the fact
that we can get on here and talk
whatever the hell we want to say and i'd
have to deal with the corporate
overlords that are uh condemning what
you're saying and if you get on cnn
which like i've been on on cnn and fox
news and these plays before it's
ridiculous they're kind of you get like
like 90 seconds maybe to like answer a
complex problem you get three hours here
yeah you sit down i'm a two-hour guy i
don't know if you noticed that i had to
step out but but i want to bring up
something important you mentioned when
it comes to running right and i'm gonna
be selfish for a moment i'm running in
new york state this year
we should be more worried about people
running this year because the impact we
make this year is going to affect 2024.
i'm in new york state if i just come in
a tight third
people will notice me i come in second
and beat the republican because my
state's three to one democrat republican
right so republican's never gonna win
the question is who comes in second
right so if i come in second that rocks
my my state my state becomes a
multi-party democracy overnight
changes everything if i win with 35
percent of the vote new york state goes
from blue to gold that changes the
entire nation let me ask you overnight
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]
you